eric lauer gets the ball has never
pitched that miller park this is his
first appearance
castianos is off to a great start
hey good pitch down and in and
castiano's chases one for strike three
in the first out for lauer that'll bring
up hey eugenio suarez
there's a swing and a miss took
something off that time suarez out in
front
back-to-back strikeouts for lauer trevor
bauer
two starts one complete game 13 in the
third innings four hits allowed one home
run punched out
20. walk three on brock holt
fastball is strike three called on the
outside corner and a nice way to get
things rolling for trevor
custom hero back-to-back strikeouts
pounding that fastball on the inside
corner is bound
well yellow just killed everybody in the
league
and another breaking ball and that's
good morning good afternoon and good
night
fanning the side is trevor bauer
so they're on the corners with one out
in the inning for
kyle farmer nothing in one red's trying
to break through here in the second
inning
and they're going to do it that one
driven
and off the glove of yellow chin to left
field cologne will score
on to third base goes winker that'll be
a double no doubt for kyle farmer and
how about that
24 straight scoreless innings now
officially over
and here's nick senzel he walked his
first time up
and this ball driven into deep left
center field will played another run
short of the track it's gamble coming in
to score is winker
two-nothing cincinnati
castellanos hooked into left field will
bring in another run
castellanos drives in his 14th of the
season
and a bottom part of this batting order
castiano's
knocking him in davidson who had a blue
shingle to right field and hitting a go
and there's a drive in a deep center
field did he get
going he got going he got
going that's a three-run big fly for the
big man
power to face first year brewer justin
smoke
and that strike three called a 94 mile
per hour fastball with a lot of movement
gamble getting the start and gamble is
gone
swinging five strikeouts already for
bauer all
five outs recorded have come via the
punch out
barbares settling in and the payoff
pitch
got him swinging six outs recorded by
bauer all
six on strikeouts here's kesten hera
is that strikeout number seven for bauer
and yellow struck out
for the 18th time in his first 37
at bats just threw a fastball right by
yelich
back-to-back case for bauer here in the
fourth inning that's
eight so far tonight
logan morrison in the deep left center
field that's got some carry to it
and this one's gonna fly out of here
logan morrison
sends one out a home run his first of
the year is first as a brewer
and the brewers are on the board runner
at first
a run in two down in the inning 2-2
pitch to gammel
and that strike three called at the
knees gamble didn't like it
nine strikeouts in this game trevor
bauer climbs the hill here in the last
of the fifth inning with the reds in
front
six to one swing and a miss
and ten strikeouts through the first
four and a third innings tonight for
trevor bauer mark matthias
swing and a miss struck him out fastball
up and out of the zone matthias climbed
the ladder
and he is strikeout victim number 11
tonight breaking ball grounded back up
the middle backhand stop colon
throw to first end time what a play by
cologne
in the outfield grass behind second base
a sliding backhanded stop popped to his
feet to throw out arcia
who's no slouch at running the bases now
trying to get irving in with a two-out
knock
is nick castellanos
in the air hit pretty well right center
field bye bye
wow holy mackerel that's number
seven for castellanos this guy is on
fire
bauer's 2-2 pitch strike three called
fastball
right over the outside corner at the
knees and that is 12
strikeouts for trevor bauer
all right here's yelich now
in the air to left center field got some
carry
and that one is up and out of here
yelling with a home run opposite field
smash a two run shot by yelich
he runs nine hits for the reds three
runs five hits for the brewers
and trying to wrap it up lucas sim 2-2
and this one belongs to the reds red's
pitching
fans 16 brewers